[Music]
what are you insinuating showing crimes
you clip from me because that does not
exist stop trying to make no one
stopping cringe Tuesday's it's a thing
now every week now let's get into the
cringe cringe time let's go Santa Santa
[Music]
is one of those where they just scream
like crazy
[Applause]
look at the judge oh please stop if I'm
competing I guess I'm like you can win
like oh my god you're so annoying Jesus
Christ next prey this one is called bad
customer service the manager at this
restaurant refused to understand me
because I mispronounced the word entree
the first time I said it he said what
what is that then I said it again entry
no he said I don't know who that is
entry entry
oh you mean entree yeah well you think I
just spoke to on the dirt room yeah
alright so uh how do you pronounce that
again okay entree entree so like when I
asked you the first time when I said
what I said entry to know what it was at
all right ng yeah cuz he Weiss
yeah right right like tomato tomahto
yeah that's that's crazy man I just need
me to order something man and you don't
have to be a smart ass about it man
yeah I rap and hold on then you're
you're being free can I have the inner
give me the entry please he uploaded
this thinking you're right that's
amazing twenty four thousand dislikes
150 likes so many delusional people out
there that get called out thanks to the
internet thanks in your name so you
acting like you're working at a fancy
restaurant every second wrong damn damn
what an idiot what good next script to
cringe time cringe time oh god I've seen
this one it's amazing you don't buy
thang was just theorem to the nearest 5
decimal places do you what's your
favorite common to you what is his name
Piers Morgan is that his name so he I
don't know if this is real or not
because they clearly fake a lot of their
sketches that he's trying to call out
this love island actress for being
stupid
and he asked what's the Pythagoras
theorem which is a2 plus b2 equals c2
but he confuses it with PI so he's like
what's the first digits of Pythagoras
here you know Pythagoras theorem to the
nearest 5 decimal places do you
Oh God three point four seven it's
certainly the first digits you don't
know the first couple digits of
detective clearly it's easy to mix a
mess it's a 3.14 15 now thank God
3.14 15 yeah Tibbs what is your deck
name it flies you guys so so far I'm
really halfway there can't you at least
chuckle I don't understand what happened
you fly she dies it's not that funny
either okay it depends on who the you
was referring and he's not wrong it
depends on the who than you is referring
to
maybe she dies maybe you dies that was a
joke
I kind of want him to just throw a fit
just go like you know if you your jokes
sucked okay I don't need
and in accordance with God's will you do
now confession
we're so good please sirs leave
oh please anywhere other than here this
is a solemn assembly not a photography
please move or I will stop I will stop
the ceremony if you do not get out of
the way this is not about god damn it
he's a photographer he's supposed to
take photos oh man this is my nightmare
me - - getting married this happens
goddamn it's two of the idiots out there
there's just too many idiots
[Laughter]
the teacher was hiding as a student and
he thought he would be slick I would
keep the cyberbullying
keep it keep the cyberbullying I mean
the best advice I would keep decipher
the cyber bullying yeah where are you
guys
tell the cyber bullies
that's right bullies ok I'm sorry haters
I'm so sorry cyber bullying just say
something like something wants to leave
your body with the record I get it stand
in front of a crowd getting stuck
getting nervous your body freezes up
you're stuck and you can't think
everyone's been there in a while except
me that's right
angry Wednesday coming up tomorrow you
better look forward to it cuz I am
getting all right what is this algae
Chloe what's for dinner tonight
this is reason
go away come on okay Chloe is not gonna
talk to me Chloe doesn't like me
evidently Chloe am I ready on my wash
rinse cycle Wow Chloe seems like such a
great product even robots have bad days
no no no fix your goddamned stupid
voice-recognition BS okay and stop
selling us the advices god damn I'm so
glad that happened because that's how it
is when you buy an lxo or whatever
elixir that's how it is like okay I just
saved you 40 pounds you're welcome okay
it's a woman shanks ball golf ball into
crowd twice J says
that's gotta hurt but you're not gonna
apologize at least check if they're all
right Jesus you could kill someone how
are they still standing there go away oh
no don't do it oh my god oh god you
can't even stop this stop Gold me yeah
arrow backup this woman is crazy this is
what I'm saying all along women not golf
I say it and they don't listen some guy
in the crowd laughter Savage that guy
must be watching cringe Tuesday's am i
right smash like if you won another
episode of cringe Tuesday's doesn't
matter because it's coming up anyway
Chris choose day it's a thing thank you
guys for watching Crim's Tuesday I'm
gonna go lay down I have a little nap
and maybe then I feel better thank you
guys bye bye what to / simulators
becoming relevant
no no don't leave no please sponsor
Eagle please do something yes this game
is still relevant
dear me